hola buenas tardes
la verdad se siente un poco extraño que
por un momento no presten atención a la
pantallita de sus celulares y miren acá
no o a la pantalla que cuenta ministro
en la pantalla
bueno
la infidelidad entre personas existe
hace muchísimo tiempo
y siempre fue un tema tabú y la
tecnología siempre estuvo un poco al
servicio de esto
hace mucho tiempo atrás
era muy común escuchar historias
acá en nuestra región de personas que
por ahí tenían dos familias una familia
en la ciudad y una familia en el campo
pero tenían una necesidad no es entonces
los datos no se cruzaban no se conocían
no sabían que tenían hermanos y demás
pero se tenían que comunicar entre ellos
y por ahí se mandaban cartas postales
o tarjetas postales y estaba el cartero
que el cartero cuando
cuando él iba a llevar la postal por ahí
la ley es ya noche está en una situación
complicada no se lo voy a dejar en la
puerta
y se la
se le entregaba en algún otro momento
era era cómplice que terminaba siendo
cómplice de esta persona
después pasar a un paso mucho tiempo
apareció el teléfono apareció en las
computadoras
pero el gran cambio estuvo cuando
apareció internet internet de forma
masiva en nuestras casas
que nos permitió en ese momento parece
un precio algo
muy bueno muy interesante que es el tema
de la virtualidad la virtualidad nos
permitía
e interactuar con personas de todo el
mundo de una forma anónima nos permitió
empezar a hacer quién queríamos ser
sin que nos vieran y sin que nos
conocieran en ese momento fines de los
años 90 a principios de los 2000
existían las salas de chat en las cuales
uno entraba y lo único que necesitaba
era poner su nombre se pone un apodo por
ejemplo los post-it o de peluche no
necesariamente ni a poner el nombre no
había una comprobación de identidad
y uno ahí era quien quería ser y en
realidad esto que quería hacer era
escrito entonces del otro lado por ahí
no sabíamos estábamos hablando con
alguien en méxico o en españa o por el
estado de la vuelta de casa y eso no lo
sabíamos y todo quedaba librado de la
interpretación porque lo único que
veíamos eran letras
y es muy común por así decirlo pero por
qué me estás gritando porque escribíamos
letras mayúsculas que si son letras no
existían todavía los mochis como estaban
hoy por hoy después todo esto fue
avanzando
empezaron a aparecer las redes sociales
las redes sociales requirió que ésta
esta virtualidad o esta posibilidad que
tuvieron todas estas personas que porque
querían expresarse y no ser
descubiertas
o poner su opinión sin poner su nombre
nos dieron esa posibilidad pero también
le agregaron contenidos empezamos a
tener la posibilidad de subir fotos de
subir audios de subir vídeos y empezar a
expresar todo eso que hacíamos
pero qué pasaba ahí todavía por lo
general las computadoras estaban en un
lugar común en una casa
y se compartía entonces esa persona que
nosotros inventamos que podía hacer 1 2
por ahí podía quedar expuestas entonces
que el problema que por ahí nos dejamos
la sesión de facebook o abierto y nos
acordamos y no el facebook quedó abierto
aquí volvíamos corriendo a casa a
cerrarlo para que no lo vean
y lo mismo en el caso de por ahí
teníamos no sé conocimos a alguien en
españa' y teníamos un chat
en una relación virtual no una relación
que capaz en nunca se concrete
y eso no nos llenaba de adrenalina por
ahí utilizábamos la compu en momentos
cuando nuestra pareja dormía y demás
pero empezamos con el tema de tener
diferentes personalidades personalidades
virtuales y personalidades reales
aparecieron sitios en este momento
sitios que se pusieron
al servicio de esto porque como toda
oportunidad siempre parece un negocio
empezaron a aparecer sitios de citas
algunos muy conocidos
apareció badu apareció
muy gracioso el título ha adoptado a un
chico y apareció a ashley madison lo que
fue muy polémico en el 2012 porque tuvo
una filtración muy grande de datos y
aparecían personas muy conocidas y
justamente el eslogan de animation era
ban sigue siendo
la vida corta
y esto este concepto se empezó a
entender cuando apareció este aparatito
no un teléfono en el cual todo está todo
ese mundo virtual que teníamos
ese mundo virtual pasó a estar en
nuestras manos y empezó a ver otro
concepto del concepto del aquí y ahora
y el tema de la necesidad de mostrar
todo el tiempo o de interactuar todo el
tiempo
con ese mundo virtual
entonces muchas veces vamos a ver yo no
sé cuántos para y vinieron al evento y
sacaron una foto diciendo estoy entero y
la subieron y cuando se estuvieron
chequeando cuantas publicaciones hubo de
del evento y por ahí nos sacamos 40
fotos elegimos una le ponemos un filtro
como que
re tocamos y tocamos la realidad para
convertirla en una realidad virtual y
paralela
que viene con el tema de la infinidad
que por ahí es muy común encontrarse con
personas que por ahí están en un bar y
uno los ve y están los dos con el
teléfono
y a su vez están diciendo bueno tienen
una relación real pero al mismo tiempo
están teniendo 123 relaciones paralelas
virtuales
que quizás se conviertan en realidad o
no pero hay un paralelismo entre la
virtualidad y la realidad y cada vez se
está transformando
en algo común lo naturalizamos de una
forma
tan profunda que la línea en que hay
entre un punto y otro entre la realidad
y la virtualidad es muy corta por
ejemplo podemos escuchar muchas veces
decir frases como mezclaba hasta el
visto
o después decir pero como si me dijiste
que te fuiste a dormir a las 11 pero
parece última conexión a las 2 de la
mañana
y bueno son conceptos que empezamos a
naturalizar y sobre todo en las
generaciones más jóvenes que lo toman
como su
su vida real de comunicación la vía como
la única vía de comunicación
entonces qué
qué importante esto de qué
de poder por ahí revalorizar lo
verdadero
por ahí diferenciar lo que es virtual o
no
pero tenemos que tener en cuenta que
esto llegó para quedarse
esto es un mundo virtual y la distinción
entre uno y otros es algo que ya está
tan naturalizado y que va a seguir
avanzando y que es un cambio
irreversible
ahora bien
en el pasado tenía teníamos al cartero
que sabía sabía de esa historia entre
estas dos personas hoy quién es el
cómplice quién es el que sabe quién
realmente somos este aparatito este
aparatito nos muestra y sabe quién
realmente somos sí sí sí nos ponemos a
hacer un repaso de los avances que van a
decir no bueno tiene contraseña tiene
patrón de código ahora con huella
digital ahora te reconoce la cara pero
si pensamos un poco toda esa protección
se creó para proteger la información de
la persona que tenemos al lado
para que no nos miren el celular no
porque siendo que tentador es mirar ese
teléfono
y qué problema cuando no nos olvidamos
del teléfono
entonces
habría que pensar no
en cinco años diez años cuando
desaparezca el teléfono quién será
nuestro próximo cómplice muchas gracias
[Aplausos]